Let me give you another example of
another
person. The person who inspired me, Shik
Ahmed
Dad. If you know his history, Shik Ahmed
Dad was only six standard
pass. And because he did not come from a
very rich family, he had to give up his
studies to make both his and his
me. So he migrates from India to South
Africa. He's born in Gujarat in
Teshwar at a young age in migration to
South Africa. And while he's doing the
job of a salesman in the furniture
shop, many Christian missionaries, they
harass him. They attack the Quran and he
has no reply. He feels very bad. I'm a
Muslim and I cannot defend my
book. So what does he do?
Once he comes across a book called as
Azar alhak the truth revealed and he
finds in that book there are answers to
the questions which are posed by the
Christian missionaries to him. He reads
that book he memorizes now he has a
mission in life that I want to give a
fitting reply to all these Christian
missionaries. So he memorizes the
book and he goes and gives a reply to
this Christian missionary. Then Allah
helps him more. He read more book. He
gets more knowledge. So much so that he
starts in the
80s in the sorry he starts much before
that in the
60s and by the time he reaches 70s and
80s he alone shake Ahmed Dat alone is
taking all the Christian missionaries of
Christianity single-handedly
alhamdulillah one man sixanded pass
didn't even pass school no
degree what was his goal setting what
does he
do he replies to the Christian
missionaries and becomes so famous
that he is asked to debate with Jimmy
Swagat some of you may have heard about
Jeff Jimmy Swagat at that time he was
the most popular Christian missionary
teleangelist
before he goes for the debate in the
early 80s he goes for a lecture tour in
Pakistan and during question answer
time there is one Pakistani who's a fan
of shik Ahmed Datad during question
answer time he says shake dedat I love
you I'm your
fan I'm requesting you do not go and
debate with Reverend Jimmy Swagat I know
him very well. He is the best speaker in
the world. He is the best orator. He
will chew you and spit you out. Imagine
a fan of Shik Ahmed Dad is telling to
shake Ahmed Dad that don't debate
Reverend Jimmy Swagad. He will chew you
and spit you. Imagine what will happen
to a state. Instead of encouraging him,
he's telling him don't
go. He will chew you and spit you aside.
Who's telling him? His
fan. I know Jimmy Swag. I have heard
him. I know him very
well. But Shik Ahmed
Dad, he has Allah's
help. He goes in USA in Louisana in his
hometown of Reverend Jimmy Swagad. He
has a debate on the topic world and that
debate is phenomenal. So much so that
after two years in 1986 Shik Ahmed Dad
gets the King Fel award for the service
of Islam. It's the highest award that
any Muslim can receive in the field of
Islam. It is like the Nobel
Prize of the Western world. Nobel Prize
is the highest award. In the same way,
King Fisel
prize for the service of Islam is the
highest prize any Muslim can get in the
field of Islam.